when we fight we face our enemy head-on  when we take their life we look them in  the eye with courage and respect  this is what makes us some right  there must be thousands of them we will  face death and defend our home  we do be musclor so kind that is why you  and I are both survivors  I am Samurai don't you want more than  that  you are the ghost convince your people  to join me and I will give them peace  never serve you  [Music]  I've never seen a samurai fight like  that it was nothing oh sure more than a  summer he is a vengeful spirit back from  the grave just slaughter the Mongols if  you continued on this path he will be no  better than the Mongols I trained you to  fight with honor honor died on the beach  the Khan deserves to suffer  [Music]  I am sorry  but I will sacrifice everything for my  home  [Music]  please